Everyone will remember Stan Lee as the lovable
grandpa of the Marvel universe...
"Are you Tony Stank?"
All those wonderful cameos aside, Stan Lee
was a cornerstone of the comics industry dating
all the way back to 1939.
For eight decades, Lee compiled a remarkable
list of achievements and changed comics forever
— but there's still plenty that many Marvel
fans don't know about his life and legacy.
Let's take some time to remember and appreciate
Stan Lee for introducing us to Earth's mightiest
heroes.
Stan Lee was born Stanley Martin Lieber in
1922, which was perfect timing to enter the
workforce during the Great Depression.
He was always interested in writing, and when
he turned 18, he got a job with Timely Comics,
the company that would later become Marvel.
It just happened to be owned by Martin Goodman,
who was married to Lee’s cousin.
How much this family connection helped Lee
get the job remains disputed.
At the time, Lee assumed his career in comics
would be short-lived, and worried that it
might hurt his ambition to become a respected
novelist.
As a result, he adopted "Stan Lee" as a pen
name and spent years introducing himself to
people simply as "a writer," without telling
them what he wrote.
Lee had been working at Marvel for less than
a year when Joe Simon and Jack Kirby discovered
that Martin Goodman had been stiffing them
out of royalties on their popular creation,
Captain America.
Outraged, Kirby and Simon quit Timely for
National Comics, the company that would later
become DC.
Goodman immediately appointed the 19-year-old
Stan Lee to replace Simon as editor-in-chief.
At the time, he had mostly written short "filler"
comics and brief text stories that were only
included so the comics could get a cheaper
rate on postage.
According to Lee, the appointment was supposed
to be temporary, but Goodman became distracted
with other branches of his publishing company
and forgot to replace him.
As it turned out, Lee remained in the post
for the next three decades, although, like
most comics creators of his generation, he
did take a few years out to serve in the army
during World War II.
It was there that he had his greatest fame
as an artist, designing posters warning soldiers
against sexually transmitted diseases, with
the catchy caption "VD?
Not Me!"
After the war, superheroes suffered a shockingly
rapid decline in popularity, and over at Timely,
all superhero comics were canceled.
Lee, desperate to stay in business, had little
room for creativity.
Despite efforts to copy other companies’
success with Westerns and monster comics,
the company repeatedly risked bankruptcy during
the 1950s, to the point that Jack Kirby said
he once came in to find Lee sobbing while
movers were taking furniture out of the office.
Goodman eventually made Lee fire all the other
employees, including many of his closest friends,
but kept Lee himself around.
When Lee was 39, he told his wife, Joan, that
he wanted to quit, but DC had recently reinvigorated
superhero comics with their new team book,
the Justice League of America.
In an attempt to replicate those sales, Lee
and Jack Kirby co-created the Fantastic Four,
a huge hit that saved the company and changed
comics history.
Steve Ditko's departure
With Steve Ditko, Stan had co-created Spider-Man
and Doctor Strange, but by the mid-60s, their
relationship had deteriorated to the point
of being almost nonexistent.
Ditko had always been a little intense, but
as his tenure on Amazing Spider-Man continued,
he attempted to inject the stories with references
to Ayn Rand's Objectivist philosophy, in which
he was an ardent believer.
That put him at odds with Lee, and eventually,
they just stopped speaking to each other,
even as they continued working on the comic.
The final straw came when the two creators
disagreed over the true identity of the Green
Goblin.
Lee wanted it to be Norman Osborn, the father
of Spider-Man's best friend; Ditko allegedly
wanted the Goblin to be an unrelated criminal.
Lee won the argument.
Ditko exited the book and was replaced by
John Romita Sr., who stayed with Marvel many
years.
Despite their disputes, Lee and Ditko were
two forces to be reckoned with — and both
left us in the same year.
Ditko passed away on June 29th of a heart
attack at the age of 90, while Lee followed
a few months later on November 12th at the
age of 95.
On the page, Stan Lee and Jack Kirby may have
been the team responsible for building the
majority of the Marvel Universe and telling
some of the best comic book stories of all
time, but behind the scenes, Kirby’s frustration
with his collaborator was growing throughout
the '60s.
To Kirby, Stan was the consummate corporate
creator, serving as the editor-in-chief and
the public face of the company that Kirby
saw as exploiting his talent.
When he started at DC, Kirby wasted no time
in making his feelings known by turning his
collaborator-turned-nemesis into a comics
character.
In the pages of Mister Miracle #6, Kirby introduced
Funky Flashman, telling readers “I know
him, you know him, but does anybody need him?"
Accompanied by a sniveling minion named Houseroy,
thought to be based on Stan’s assistant,
Roy Thomas, Flashman was a con man out to
exploit others’ talent, and was first seen
taking an allowance that was automatically
dispensed from a statue, literally pulling
the money out of someone else’s head
Despite the bad blood, Kirby and Lee were
able to make peace in 1993, shortly before
Kirby’s passing.
"I don't think there's any artist in the field
today who doesn't owe Jack something."
In the 1960s, Marvel was just a small division
of a company called Magazine Management, and
they weren't actually the most profitable
part of the company.
That honor went to a line of "Men's
Magazines" with extremely creative names like
Stag, Male, and Complete Man.
Sensing an opportunity to capitalize on that
success, Lee decided to combine Magazine Management's
two most prominent departments.
The result was The Adventures of Pussycat,
which made its debut in 1965 as what Lee called
a “cutie” comic.
"Oh man…"
While Lee's gamble on The Adventures of Pussycat
didn't really pay off, the scandalous story
included work from Lee, Wally Wood, and Al
Hartley, who wound up leaving Pussycat and
Marvel after finding religion.
He spent his remaining career drawing Christian-themed
Archie comics.
It's easy to argue that Stan's most important
role wasn't as a comic book writer or editor
but as an ambassador for the medium.
Long before he was a notable cameo in the
world's most popular movies, he served his
ambassador role with a set of videos designed
to give viewers a look behind the scenes of
the comic book industry.
Released on VHS in 1991, The Comic Book Greats
was a 12-part documentary series hosted by
Lee where he interviewed creators about their
process.
Not only did it feature legends like Batman
co-creator Bob Kane, it also put the spotlight
on some of the hottest creators of the era.
Among the most interesting segments are Stan's
interviews with Jim Lee, Todd McFarlane, Rob
Liefeld, and Whilce Portacio, four of the
artists whose incredible success at Marvel
would lead them to found Image Comics.
McFarlane and Liefeld's interviews even managed
to feature obscure first appearances of a
characters that would later make their way
into the comics.
Challenged by Stan to create a whole new hero
or villain on a tight time limit, Liefeld
drew Die Hard, a future member of his super-team,
Youngblood — and quickly had a cheerful
Stan asking questions about what he called
our new character.
Stan always had a knack for following trends,
so it's no surprise that in 1998, he co-founded
a company called Stan Lee Media in order to
produce "webisodes" for an Internet audience
— including an animated comic about the
Backstreet Boys.
"No way!
I hate when that happens."
It also shouldn't be surprising that in 2000,
when the dotcom bubble burst, SLM went defunct
and filed for bankruptcy.
What happened after that, however, nobody
saw coming.
The short version is that SLM claimed that
Lee assigned all of the rights to his characters
to the company, and they've been suing Marvel,
Disney, and Lee himself for billions of dollars
since 2007.
"Do what I ask or Earth and all your friends
are doomed."
It probably goes without saying, but the lawsuits
and appeals have consistently been called
"frivolous" and dismissed in court.
Lee himself did his best to extract himself
from both the company and its ongoing legal
mess.
Unfortunately, the one thing that isn't in
dispute is that they own the name "Stan Lee
Media," linking Lee's name to their actions
despite his best efforts to shut them down.
"Ah, forget it."
The ups and downs of Stan Lee's career aside,
he co-created and helped introduce some of
our favorite characters to the world.
With the help of late, great legends like
Jack Kirby and Steve Ditko, Stan Lee made
the Fantastic Four, Spider-Man, the X-Men,
Iron Man, Thor, Black Panther, the Hulk, and
many other iconic characters household names.
As the Marvel Cinematic Universe is starting
to eclipse its printed counterparts in terms
of pop culture influence and recognition,
we should remember Stan Lee for being the
wonderful grandfather of superherodom that
he was, whether it was being the ambassador
to the comic book industry or giving Peter
Parker amazing advice on-screen.
"I guess one person can make a difference…
enough said."